Que los municipios socialicen
mediante los medios de comunicación
los derechos de los animalitos
para que todas las personas
que tengamos conocimiento de algún
eh de alguna vulneración hacia los animalitos
puedan denunciar.
Esta se tiene que denunciar así como cualquier
tú si tienes conocimiento puedes llamar a la policía
o puedes sacar fotos y denunciar,
puedes ir a la hasta la FCC
y darles la conocer de que sea
vulnerable a los derechos de los animalitos
tienen la obligación de continuar con la investigación,
de hacerle citar a esa persona.
Sin embargo um
la pena no es mucha,
para el caso de los maltratos
es de 6 meses a un año y eso
o cuando es un año no, no entran a la cárcel,
en en cambio a si matan un animal es de 2 a 5 años.
En ese caso sí podrían entrar a la cárcel
porque con un año,
cuando la pena es de un año,
generalmente salen con un perdón judicial
o una salida alternativa,
o sea no, no van a la cárcel